il préfère te mens tu rebondis là ils
partent pieusement pèlerinage à rome
messieurs attention le voyage va être
fort l'an pour atteindre le double de
saint pierre où il apporte en offrant
des bonbonnes de ses excellents va des
corbières et du minervois
messieurs les 3,3 retard j'ai le choix
je partis les ont tout à l'heure de
renoir à tanus
oui ils sont pris le micro monsieur
cizeron ne vient d'être blessé
park est apparent chez de l'ambitieux je
ne sais pas pourquoi ce chiffre alors
nous allons minutes et je vous demande
infiniment pardon dit oui je n'y va plus
rien je n'ai rien à l'oeil mais l'on m'a
cassé mes lunettes
par conséquent nous allons voir comment
nous allons faire le tir à la corde
malheureusement sans lunettes je ne peux
rien faire on va essayer d'y parer par
conséquent nous allons improvisé mais
malheureusement un jeu n'est plus tout à
fait comme et moyens m
s'il vous plaît qu'ims vendangeurs sont
les risques du métier léo instrumentant
dé leon leon rendez-vous les eaux ici
carcassonne apple taxes ici captation
d'appel dax je voudrais que les ondes de
répondre aux menaces que léon zitrone me
répondez moi ici je vous appelle de
carcassonne un luxe inouï à lui ce
monsieur si on est en train de se faire
soigner
oui j'ai bien compris mais est-ce que
nous pouvons poursuivre les messieurs ce
qui n'est pas blessé n'y a rien on
savait que j'avais pas grave ça fait mal
ça n'est pas grave dit luc se
construisait l'émission oui oui mais on
je vous demande pardon dit non ils n'ont
pas non plus je voudrais aussi rassurer
des miens qui sont dans leurs écrans et
leur dire que finalement en dehors du
fait qu'on m'a cassé mes lunettes et que
je n'y vois rien tout va bien mais c'est
claude savary qui vraisemblablement a
commenté dans un
par le canada corp merci en tous les cas
nous sommes rassurés sur le sort de léon
je regrette quand même les incidents qui
viennent d'avoir lieu à dax je trouve ça
un petit peu extraordinaire dans un jeu
qui a pour mission de distraire la
france entière qu'il y ait quelques
énergumènes qui est prennent mal la
victoire ou la défaite de telle ou telle
ville et de s'en prendre aux animateurs
prouvé une fois de plus qu'il y a quand
même des gens qui ne sont à leur place
nulle part de toute façon nous sommes
rassurés sur le sort des environs et
avant toute chose je dois vous le dire
l'amitié parle et j'ai eu un moment
d'émotion et j'aurais même stopper
immédiatement intervilles la finale et
les résultats n'auraient pas compter si
mon grand ami leon avait eu la moindre
blessure il est là il est debout il
pourra certainement présenter le tir à
la corde
nous sommes rassurés j'espère qu'à dax
là bas la police à la fois la
municipalité et les gens de bonne
qualité seront faire la police pour
faire sortir les quelques énergumènes
qui se sont ainsi manifesté à l'eau
propre de toute la télévision et
maintenant nous revenons à notre jeu
dans la bonne humeur avec simone garnier
et des moines qui j'espère vont amener
le sourire car après tout bon un
incident n'est qu'un incident ne le
grossiste ont pas vu tu as bien louer
après ces émotions nous retrouvons nos
moines ces moines qui sont tous prêts à
partir